fred savage grew up in front of our eyes
on the original wonder years but now
fred's tv legacy is in question welcome
to entertainment tonight michelle turner
is off the 45 year old has dealt with
past allegations on set before but in a
dramatic turn of events fred is out of
the wonder years reboot
the internal investigation resulted in
him being fired from his job as a
director and executive producer on the
reboot of the wonder years
so what allegedly happened one report
cited verbal outbursts and inappropriate
behavior another claimed three separate
allegations of misconduct this comes as
a surprise just eight months ago the
cast told us this it's wonderful to sit
back and see fred work with ej on here
on the set and fred is the only one who
laughs at my joke so i really appreciate
it
a source tells e.t that the actor's
dismissal was supposed to be an internal
matter without publicity and quote it
was surprising to many involved when the
alleged details were leaked
but this is not the first time savage
has been accused of misconduct mr savage
was aggressive towards me he would
routinely curse at me yell at me demean
me
in 2018 this former costume designer
from the fox comedy the grinder accused
the actor of assault battery and
harassment during a taping of an episode
i was attempting to brush off dandruff
off mr savage's jacket
mr savage snapped and he hit my arm
violently three times
i could not stop crying i was in pain i
was humiliated and i was scared
the actor denied the claims the case was
settled out of court that same year
allie mills who played fred's mom on the
wonder years said the original series
came to an end in 1993 due to a
completely ridiculous sexual harassment
suit that was going on against fred
savage who was like the least offensive
most wonderful sweet human being it was
so not true
savage denied the allegation and that
case was also settled out of court
it would feel great if it became a hit
e.t first talked to fred as an 11 year
old just days before the debut of the
wonder years
it's about um
a
12 and a half year old
kid who grows up
in the
looked
1960s
from both sides now
as soon as my head starts getting bigger
it's
over it's really bad then
[Music]
you